[Music]
did you ever wonder what would happen if
the Disney Princesses turned evil we've
reimagined the ladies as villains and
their evil powers are certainly scary
keep watching to discover which
princesses would team up to deliver
their villainous ways Elsa it would be
pretty easy for Elsa to turn evil after
all we got a taste of what that would be
like when she first set up shop on the
North Mountain of frozen Queen Elsa
already has ice powers so all she'd need
to do is use them for bad for anything
good she could freeze hearts
deliberately and she could create her
very own army of evil snow monsters led
by marshmallow Anna as Elsa's sister it
makes sense for Anna to have secret
powers too so it's not much of a stretch
to think of Oh No
wielding fire powers and boy oh boy
could she unleash serious evil with that
her and Elsa could have an ultimate
showdown we loved Ana's new look brought
to us by tumblr artists stirring wind
Rapunzel there's a definite theme of
stealing in Rapunzel's life story
mother Gothel stole her when she was a
baby she fell in love with a thief so it
makes sense that Rapunzel would turn to
a life of crime if she turned evil as a
villain she travel around the world
taking expensive trinkets from the rich
and what about her weapon of choice a
frying pan of course keep watching to
find out which other princess she could
team up with Tiana Tiana has mad skills
as a chef but what if she decided to use
those powers with evil intent she could
brew up poisonous potions to feed
unsuspecting customers and she could
then take a leaf out of dr. fassl ears
book and perform voodoo magic on her
victims we can just imagine which other
princess she'd be in cahoots with stay
tuned for that reveal Ariel as evil
Ariel the princess could take
inspiration from her arch nemesis Ursula
just like the sea witch Ariel could grow
slippery arms and bully all the
underwater creatures what would she do
if they disobeyed spray them with toxic
ink this is one queen of the ocean you
would not want to cross
love this piece by fan pop artist listed
her oh one seven Bell how about this
four bells evil power book imprisonment
we all know that Bell loves to read so
if she became a villain chances are
she'd use that love of literature for
evil purposes
she could turn her enemies into book
characters and trap them forever in a
hardback do you think she turned Prince
Adam back into the Beast and transformed
him inside the pages of a book or would
he be her accomplice jasmine a
villainous Jasmine would need to look
far for inspiration on how to behave
badly if Jasmine got hold of Jafar staff
she could unleash all sorts of evil and
what would be her most shocking act
trapping Aladdin in a sand timer and not
letting him escape
Moana Moana has power over the ocean so
if she decided to use that for evil
deeds she could be a terrifying force
she could cause floods and tsunamis and
totally destroy whole Islands just
imagine her with glowing green eyes as
if the heart of toffee tea had been
transplanted into her face freaky right
Pocahontas Pocahontas loves nature so it
would be a complete turnaround for this
Disney Princess to turn against the
earth just like the villain in her movie
governor Ratcliffe Pocahontas could
destroy the planet by digging it up she
could take that evil even further by
deliberately ripping out trees and
leaking toxins into rivers Merida we
could just imagine Merida creating her
own bare army to destroy the clan
surrounding her homeland
mordioux would have nothing on this
arrow wielding maniac
she's one of the Disney Princesses that
has the kind of skill that could be used
for evil should she choose to turn to
the dark side we'd be worried for her
mom Queen Eleanor evil Merida would do
more damage than simply ripping up a
tapestry Aurora sleeping spells are
nothing new for Aurora but the Sleeping
Beauty could switch up the ending if she
turned evil she could take inspiration
from Maleficent and put spells on all
the sharp objects in the land soon
everyone in her kingdom would be out for
the count sleeping for a hundred years
and then she could take advantage of the
lull and steal everything in sight she
looks the wicked
Cinderella Cinderella knows a thing or
two about turning rags into riches as a
villain she could do a switcheroo and
turn everyone's riches into rags just
imagine if she got hold of the fairy
godmothers wand and used it to create
some bibbidi-bobbidi-boo spells in
Reverse she could even use it against
her fellow Disney Princesses
Snow White they say the poisoned apple
doesn't fall far from the tree so Snow
White could follow in the Evil Queen's
footsteps if she became a villain he'd
skip through the forest offering her
basket of apples to innocent passers-by
she'd make the evilest of teams with
tiana brewing up new poisons to try out
on their unsuspecting victim which
princess would you love to see as a
villain let us know in the comments make
sure to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]